welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Watson adventures in game and infinity
war ultimate scenes and rejected
concepts just keep pouring out for the
filmmaking team with one of the most
interesting deleted Thanos backstories
revealed by the screenwriters and folks
I just can't get enough of talking about
this purple roid head and the secret
life of his because whether he's
decapping cap or having the ghosts of
his victims grope him at the feet of a
giant golden multi phase space god it's
always fascinating to consider Nick
Brolin at the heart of it all
specifically there's the mystery of how
Thanos acquired the power stone before
the events of Avengers infinity war we
know the power stone was previously
locked away Ahn's and are after the
events of guardians of the galaxy then
Dana's just showed up with it in the
opening minutes of infinity war sure we
could all put one and one together and
assumes and Ark is probably a smoldering
wreck but now we have been given some
new wrinkles and that off-screen
backstory spoiler warning because people
yell at me if I don't say that okay
these screenwriters of Avengers in game
and infinity war Christopher Markus
Stephen McFeely revealed that early
drafts of the infinity war script did
actually show that os-- taking the power
stone from Xander before either infinity
war or in game came out you may remember
some quotes from the creative team
describing the plot as a heist movie in
retrospect they may have been referring
to the time heist of the second half of
the story and endgame but there really
wasn't anything hasty about Thanos's
stone quest and infinity war he grabs
the space stone by killing Loki the
reality stone my wrecking nowhere of
which we only see the aftermath the soul
stone by killing Gamora the time stone
right beaten up The Avengers on Titan in
the mine stone by popping it out of
visions head and what conduct there's
really nothing sneaky about the stuff
for heist it got a sneak a little hide
behind a pillar or to wear a disguise
salute your own ass you know that US
would love this sneak a salute to his
own but so yes originally we were going
to see Thanos steal the Power Stone from
zan Darb a word I really gotta stop
saying this was not going to be a
smash-and-grab job and it wasn't going
to be the opening scene in the film but
rather come in a completely different
stone gathering order so originally
thanasis did not have the power stone in
the opening to seeing them infinity war
presumably his forces were going to
wreck Thor Loki Hulk the other as
Guardians went out any of the stones and
getting this space stone from Luque was
stone one then
next step was to go to the collectors
vault on nowhere for the reality stone
stone to which would then lead to Xander
for the Power Stone and that scene the
screen artists revealed was going to be
a massive battle initially they said
that this is and our battle was going to
come before nowhere but then they
clarified that it was a battle that
involved the reality stone meaning after
nowhere so this version of the story
would have changed Thanos his journey in
two key ways one his natural philosophy
would have been far more severe because
he would have been able to take out Thor
and Hulk without an infinity stone now
when Thanos boxed Hulk many notice that
the Power Stone was not lit up meaning
he was fighting without its power but
still it means the rest of the damage to
the Asgardians would have been done
stone lists as well but to this version
would have shown the reality stone used
to wreak far more havoc than we saw in
the final version of Infinity Ward like
at the version we saw it's used to
temporarily turn Drax and mantas into
blocks and ribbons and quills
blaster-bolt into bubbles and generally
tricked them all with a smoke screen and
then later on Titan it's used for like a
slide show and briefly to manipulate the
ground beneath dr. Strange's feet but
instead in the alternate version we
could have seen Bannos use the reality
stone to literally rip Xander to shreds
Nova Corps fleet popping like popcorn
kernels Glenn closes Nova primer on a
rail trapped in a giant mousetrap john c
reilly is roman de squeezed inside out
with his eyes popping out rolling around
on the ground like marbles for his
clumsy inside our body to slip on yeah
no matter what tom foolery was going
down the streets of the xandarians city
would be covered in an ocean of blood
this or there probably some less violent
version of this booing is these and our
battle that the screenwriters conceived
not a smash-and-grab heist with Stannis
in the black order like portal II and
into the sand our vault to snatch the
Power Stone orb and they do easy instead
a cartoonishly delightful spectacle is
the mad Titan in the combined strengths
of the space stone and the reality stone
humiliate the most pompous but also the
most frequently dominated planet of the
Marvel Universe
now the reason the screenwriters cut
this is because they felt the battle
wouldn't have carried its weight
story-wise that pretty much every other
scene in these movies has to accomplish
multiple goals at once
for example Thanos says scenes with
Gamora both move the plot forward a
and established their father/daughter
relationship to set the emotional stakes
for when he has to sacrifice her the
writers wanted each Stowe to carry
emotional weight so that Venus is
acquiring each came with a heartbreaking
cost low key for the space stone Gamora
for the soul stone vision for the mine
stone the surrender of Gamora for the
reality stone the surrender of Tony
Stark and Doctor Strange for the time
stone and with the power stones and art
the writers felt that we just wouldn't
have the same connection with Glenn
Close or john c reilly and that they'd
have to set up like the guardians of the
galaxy vacationing ons and ours so that
they could play a role in this part
ultimately starting the movie with
Thanos already having a Power Stone
gives a story more initial momentum and
it suggests the conclusion of something
that we probably didn't need to see on
screen to understand but do you think
this Xander battle Power Stone scene
should have been included and infinity
war would it have made the movie better
comment down below with your thoughts
and follow me on Instagram and Twitter a
da vas and subscribe to new rock stars
for breakdowns and theories about
everything Marvel thanks for joining me
and if you take anything away from this
episode remember heist requires sneak
know sneak know heist Ocean's eleven
well that's a sneak heist Fast Five
dragging a safe through real folks day
great movie but less sneak so unless
heist a fun fact the rock cannot sneak
[Music]